a year has passed since Anthony left the
front line for home the fighting may now
be hundreds of kilometers away but the
conflict still hasn't let him go time
and time again his thoughts turned to
the Donbass I was dragging a wounded
friend through the snow to safety you
fall down and the bullets are flying
over your head you get a few meters
further and just end up falling down
again because the fire is so heavy
Andrey spent three years on the
frontlines in Donbass as tensions rose
he volunteered with the nationalist Azov
battalion it was simply the fastest way
to get to the front he tells us later he
served as a paramedic the constant
vigilance that saved under his life in
the trenches is now getting in the way
of adjusting to normal life he's just
one of thousands of veterans returning
home to find that the war continues in
their minds and their bodies it happens
really suddenly everything can be fine
and then I get all hot I lose control
over my arms and legs my heart starts
beating like crazy and my blood pressure
jumps sometimes I get a full-scale panic
attack
those are just some of the symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD
but for all that Andrey sometimes wishes
he could return to the frontline life as
a civilian isn't easy he doesn't expect
gratitude Andrey tells us but even
finding work as a struggle many
businesses won't employ veterans for
fear they could turn violent and Buddy
has yet to receive any support from the
government we put this - the Ukrainian
military they say the problem has been
overstated of course soldiers returning
from battle have trouble readjusting
that could be anything from heightened
agressivity to anxiety or depression but
all that passes after three days at home
but when you're moving up the losses
more than 600 soldiers on active duty
have taken their own lives since the
conflict began so says Ukraine's top
military prosecutor it's a statistic
that's been making headlines in Ukraine
for months but the Army's top brass
dismisses the figure looks really weak
the true numbers are no higher than the
Ukrainian average it would be wrong to
say that we have a critical situation
with suicides in the Ukrainian army
instead activists are filling the gap
left by government
we're in via vena high up in the
Carpathian Mountains about as far as you
can get from the frontline veterans like
Andrea can come here to take a break and
receive support from psychologists and
art therapists it's an opportunity
that's only possible thanks to private
donations for the next 10 days Anthony
will be sharing every moment of every
day with the group none of whom he knew
before coming here I don't want to see
anybody is any flowers all I want you to
do is experiment with the colors before
the war the talena Muslim vote was an
art teacher what began as well and
tearing soon became a full-time job
helping veterans to find their feet but
how do you get adults let alone soldiers
to paint
yom-yom oh no I always say just do it
try our participants are always
astonished when they see that they can
produce something of beauty what we're
doing here is to create an atmosphere of
trust in a safe place we're surrounded
by a beautiful landscape they can
finally let go and think about what they
want to do with their lives
when did you last draw it's been a while
oh come on it's been 35 years at least
I've never done anything like this I'm
glad I came here I'm just in a really
good mood the group heads up the
mountain towards a cabin the vitalina
hopes will eventually become a permanent
home for the project but it's not just
about the landscape ludecke the
villagers help our veterans to make
sense of who it was they were actually
fighting for they meet people who are
truly grateful to them that's really
important chopping wood picking apples
or just letting go it's a welcome break
after an intense few days no one can be
sure how lasting an impact such a short
stay can have but already Andrea seems
like a changed man one with a plan talk
with the bauhaus I want to use the
experiences I've gained here to help
others like me I've seen myself how
tough it is
I'll EFT the army a year ago and still
can't find peace it won't be easy the
waiting list for this project is already
closed vitalina tells us the donations
have simply dried up